hello everyone my name is brandon
lussier
and today i'm going to be talking about
quasi-linear mechanisms for
non-quasi linear agents this is joint
work with moshe pobioff richard cole
jason hartline and nicole and morlika
uh so let's talk about algorithmic
maximum design um and so i'm going to
start by giving a little context
for those who might not be familiar and
do this through a simple
sort of toy example um that will be a
recurring example through the talk
it's a very straightforward allocation
problem i'm going to assume there's some
pool of users
right pink and purple here um and a
collection of goods
apple and banana that the users have
value for
we assume the user's values are additive
okay so each user has some value
for each good um and if you get multiple
goods
your value is just the sum of the values
for the individual goods okay so the
pink user's value for getting the apple
and the banana in this case would be
three
our goal as a designer is to partition
the goods amongst users
to maximize some objective which might
be for example total value
of the assignment now you might notice
in this case that that objective is
super trivial
um you would obviously just give the
banana to the pink user and the
apple to the purple user to maximize
total value four
the thing that makes this a little bit
challenging is that those values aren't
known to us they're private knowledge to
users
and we assume the users are strategic
and might misreport them to maximize
their own gains
right this is where the game theoretic
part comes in there's sort of a standard
mechanism design solution to this kind
of problem which is to charge payments
okay so now as a designer we're not just
going to choose
which subset of the goods each agent
gets but also how much they pay and a
common assumption
is that um each agent wants to maximize
the value of the goods that they get
which we can now think of as being
measured in dollars
minus the amount they pay right this
assumption is called quasi linearity
and you might you know hint from the
title
we're going to be revisiting this
assumption in this talk but for now
let's just take it as given
right under that assumption there's a
very nice solution to this optimization
problem which handles the incentive
problems which is called the vcg
mechanism
in this case it has a very simple form
what we do is for each item
right so the agents would declare their
values for each item and then for each
of the goods
we would give the good to whoever had
declared the highest value
and have them pay the second highest
value right so in this case
the pink user would get the banana
because they had the highest bid of two
and they would pay one dollar because
that was the second highest bid made by
the purple user
and a classic result for mechanism
design is that this particular way of
setting up the allocation and payments
um will incentivize every everyone to
report their values truthfully
in the sense that no matter what the
purple agent declares
right the pink user will always maximize
their gain
right maximize their utility by
declaring their true value for both the
apple opener
now there's a specific case of a very
general you know
property of the vcg mechanism which
you know holds for a very broad class of
allocation and social choice problems
beyond just this additive case
um and there's now a rich theory uh
within sort of the
economics and computation literature
that extends
um that theory the vcg mechanism to
various classes of approximation
algorithms as well
right um and it's a beautiful theory
it also has a lot of applications to
sort of real markets
right this applies to online advertising
platforms cloud resource scheduling and
pricing
two-sided markets like ride sharing and
crowdsourcing
in a lot of these cases we have a theory
of how users will respond to prices
that sort of builds on this
quasi-linearity of assumption
the thing i want to point out is that
this quasi-linear assumption is very
crucial
right to this result right our analysis
which shows that agents will behave
or report truthfully requires that they
think about the trade-off between value
and payment in this
way and in particular that they have a
linear value
for money and i want to note that um
while this is very standard in mechanism
design it's not uncontroversial
sort of within economics more broadly
right a more
general model um is to have the
disutility for spending money not
necessarily be linear in the amount of
money spent
but some convex function of the amount
of money spent
all right what this captures is the
notion that each marginal dollar
spent buying apples and bananas is
weakly more
costly than the last in the sense it's
somewhat more painful
right it costs more utility now why
should we think of this as why is this
reasonable right like why why do we care
about non-linearity and convexity
well this captures of various notions
and behavioral things that we observe in
practice
right so for example it captures the
idea of hard or soft budgets
right users usually don't have unlimited
access to funds
and so when they're spending money on
your mechanism your allocation
algorithm every dollar they spend is a
dollar they could have spent somewhere
else
right so maybe they have some disposable
income right so at first they willing to
spend money up to their value
but then eventually they start spending
enough they start realizing like okay if
i spend more than maybe i should skip my
latte
uh today and if i spend even more than
that okay maybe i'll have to take out a
loan
uh to make my rent and eventually at
some point they'll just they might be
unable to spend more money
right and so this is like we can think
of this as a convex disk utility for
spending more
um this applies to like the individual
users also implies to firms right so you
can imagine for example an advertising
platform
right when i'm thinking about how much
an advertiser is going to spend
well that advertise probably has some
advertising budget that they're
splitting across different channels
right so when they're spending a dollar
on my platform the value of the dollar
isn't just a dollar
it's how much value they could have
gotten from that dollar somewhere else
and that might not be linear right this
also captures ideas notions of risk
aversion
right so you might imagine um that you
know the
the quasi-linear assumption this linear
value for money
presumes that say agents would be
completely indifferent between getting a
million dollars for sure
and having a 50 50 lottery between
getting nothing or getting two million
dollars
um i don't know about you but i
personally would have a strong
preference for just the million dollars
right at that sort of stakes um i'd much
rather you know have that first million
dollars for sure
because the second million dollars is
much less valuable than the first to me
um and again if you apply that logic to
how people will spend money that would
translate to a convex disutility
for spending their money okay so our
main question is
you know if we actually believe that you
know this quasi-linearity assumption
you know while convenient doesn't
necessarily model reality especially
like in certain contexts
what would happen if we took this theory
of mechanism design for quasi-linear
agents
and all of the you know constructions
and best practices that come out of that
theory
and deploy them in environments where in
fact the agents might not be quasi
linear
right how robust is this theory to
non-quasi linearity behavior that users
might actually exhibit
so what do we find well suppose we do
exactly that suppose we take a mechanism
that would be truthful for quasi-linear
agents
um and deployed in an environment where
agents have convex disutility for
payments
uh now the mechanism might no longer no
longer be truthful all right the agents
aren't even reporting
um these disutility curves but it turns
out that at equilibrium
the agent can best respond in a way that
sort of has a nice structure
right agents have a best response where
they take their evaluation functions
and scale them down by a uniform scalar
multiple
and that scalar is actually
interpretable it will correspond to the
return on investment that the agent is
getting
at equilibrium and this applies not just
to this
added setting we talked about before but
actually a broad class of social choice
problems
uh similar to the set of problems which
the vcg mechanism applies
um now you might ask uh you know we know
something about the structure of these
equilibria but like
what happens in these allocations like
are they any good if we restrict our
attention back to this additive case
like the example we discussed at the
beginning we can show a price of anarchy
style result
right now um we want to show that the
the
outcomes have good welfare we have to be
careful about the way we define welfare
here
we're no longer in quasi-linear settings
transfers between agents you know
potentially coming to lost utility what
we do is we define a notion of welfare
we call transferable welfare
which extends the notion of liquid
welfare that's used a lot when
discussing mexican design for agents
with budgets
we're going to talk more about that
definition later
but it turns out that for this notion of
welfare transferable welfare
we show that at any equilibrium of this
mechanism and there could be many
but at any equilibrium with the
mechanism we're going to end up getting
at least half
of the optimum we also have a price
range
style result for revenue as well um but
uh
i'm not going to talk about that very
much in this talk but please see the
paper for more details about that
okay so before going into the details i
want to make a note about related work
there's a very rich set of papers
that looks at mechanism design sort of
beyond quasi linearity
where we see agents
with you know different utility models
like budget constraints
or having risk aversion generally the
way these papers work is that you design
a mechanism
that's targeting um the the a good
outcome
when agents have this particular type of
utility function
we're doing something different here
which is that we're looking at the
mechanisms that
are designed you know that are truthful
for quadrant agents and asking how
robust
those mechanisms are when we go into
these environments where agents are not
necessarily quasi-linear
i also want to point out in particular
um a
line of work that looks at
budget-constrained agents
um for advertising platforms it turns
out that from you know
technically is very similar to the sort
of results that we're doing
and you can interpret a lot of our you
know technical work
as taking these ideas from mechanisms
in uh advertising platforms with budgets
and extending it to more general notions
of uh convex
cost for spending money
great now let's get into a little bit
more of the deep the details of the
model
right so we're going to have again this
this allocation problem with n agents
and m goods
um assume additive values across the
goods like in our example before
some of our results actually apply much
more generally uh than added evaluations
to other social choice problems
but for now let's focus on the additive
case uh i'll get to those
generalizations later
um we'll now have this cost of money
curve which we think of as this
convex disutility for spending money um
we assume it's non-decreasing
weekly convex also for technical reasons
we're going to assume
um that there's a lower bound uh on its
derivative so that
you know there is some disutility uh for
spending money everywhere
which will normalize to being one and so
now the utility of an agent given a
certain outcome will be the value they
get from their location
minus uh their disutility from payments
so for some examples of this of these
disk utility curves
we can capture the quasi linear case by
having the curve be the the identity
function
um we could have cip be some other
coefficient times p which you can think
of as modeling
on bidder who wants a certain return on
investment target right so they would
have some out other way that they could
spend money that gives them at least our
units of utility per dollar
and so they needed most that at least
that much value um to consider spending
money on the platform
uh we can also handle hard budget
constraints by matching a cost function
that is
the identity function up to some value b
uh and in which case it just shoots up
to positive infinity
okay and we can imagine capturing soft
budgets and things like that as well
um and more generally like arbitrary
convex curves
so again so our result the main
characterization result
is that we fix any mechanism that would
be truthful
for quasi-linear agents right
then for any setting of the valuation
functions v
and any choice of the cost of money
curve c
which could be different for different
agents take any agent i
and look at any setting of the bids of
the others then there's always a best
response for bitter i
which takes their valuation function vi
and scales it by some
scalar multiple alpha between zero and
one right so they always scale their
values down
they could choose alpha equals one in
which case they don't scale down at all
but it could be also less than one and i
want to point out
that this vi is a function and the alpha
i
the vi is a function and the alpha i is
a scalar okay so in general
like more generally an agent could
declare sort of an arbitrary function
to the mechanism and what this is saying
is that in fact to get a best response
you don't need the power
to report arbitrary functions um there's
always the best response it just takes
your original function and scales it by
a uniform scaling factor
moreover there's a pure nash equilibrium
where each agent bids in this way
right so not only are their best
responses there actually is an
equilibrium where everyone bids this way
i want to point out that the existence
of pure natural equilibrium requires
some delicacy around tie breaking
that i'm going to sort of slide under
the carpet in this talk
but please see the paper for more
details about this
i also want to emphasize that i'm
talking about pure nash equilibrium here
in particular the model
is not a model of bayesian updating
with stochastic valuations we're
assuming the valuations are fixed
and we're looking at equilibria of the
resulting game where the agents are
declaring their reports the mechanism
let me go through an example just to
just to make sure that we we understand
the the model
so let's go back to this example with
the apple and the banana and let's
assume that the agents now don't aren't
quasilinear
but they have this particular cost of
money curve
where they're quasi linear up to a
payment of 50 cents
at which point it becomes more painful
than spend money
right after 50 cents the value for
spending money is four units of utility
per dollar spent
now in this case suppose that they
reported truthfully which remember was a
was a good idea for them
if their value if their cost of money
curves were quasi-linear
if the agents declare alpha equals
choose alpha equals one
which means that they just report their
valuations unchanged
then they would just report those values
directly to the mechanism shown here in
red
remember the mechanism is this this vcg
mechanism
which says allocate each good to the
highest bidder and make them pay the
second highest bid
so these are the bidders that win each
agent ends up paying
a value which is the second highest bid
on that good
now the payment of say the pink user is
now one
and we can look up in this on this curve
how much disutility that generates for
them
which we can see is 2.5 units of
disutility
and so if we look at the utility they
get from this outcome well
they each get two units of utility from
the good they got
but they lose two and a half units due
to their payment
right this is the disutility from their
payment which is less than zero so
certainly this isn't the best response
for either of them
right they'd each be better off actually
not participating in the auction at all
they could have instead each scaled
their values down
by say half right by which i mean for
the pink user they would take their
value for the apple and declare half
of it and the banana and declare half of
that then the values that they declare
with maximum are these in red
we can go through the same calculation
um the same
the same agents will win um but the
payments are now less
and we can look up now on the curve and
the disk utility from payment
is actually much smaller now right
because it's below this soft budget of
0.5
they each actually just just
suffer 0.5 units of disutility for that
for that money that they spent
so they each get positive utility two
units of utility from their
mount they they from what they uh got
0.5 from what they spent
and actually this is that you can see
that this is a an equilibrium as well
right so for example the pink user could
bid
higher in order to say win the apple
right they could bid more than one on
the apple and win it
but if they did that they would have to
pay at least a dollar for the apple
because that's what the pink player is
that's what the purple player is
declaring on the apple
but their dis utility for spending an
extra dollar given that they're already
spending 0.5
would be 4 which is higher than their
value for the apple so they wouldn't
want to do that
and similarly the other way so actually
this is an equilibrium
now it turns out it's not the only
equilibrium right there are other
scaling factors that work as well
for example suppose the pink player
scales their valuation down by
a third and the purple player scales
down
her valuation by less right by say two
thirds
then these red values are what gets
declared to the mechanism
and we can see what what would the
second price auction do
well the purple player certainly wins
the apple
right because four-thirds is higher than
one-third but there's a tie on the
banana
either way we resolve that tie the price
on the banana
will be two-thirds okay
um so let's imagine that we break the
tie
by splitting by sort of randomizing one
third
uh one quarter um to the purple player
and three quarters to the pink player
and have them each pay
their corresponding fraction of the
price
well then one can work out that each
player is actually paying 0.5
here just like in the alpha equals 0.5
uh case
and if you work through that the
utilities um you get some quantities
which are still positive
but neither player in this case is
actually willing to bid higher
because the marginal value like the cost
to spending more money
is so high per unit right that even
though the pink player
has a much higher value per unit of the
banana than the purple player
they're not willing to spend more to get
to sort of break the ties more in their
favor
so in fact we get a equilibrium here as
well
and so there are multiple equilibria of
this game um
and not all equilibria results in you
know this this good outcome
where each player gets the item that's
most valuable to them
what our result shows is that all
equilibria
have this form where there are always
equilibria of this form
where the players are declaring these um
alpha
values right so they're scaling their
evaluations by some
uniform scalar alpha um
and moreover um as we'll show a little
bit later
um these can differ in the total
you know welfare generated under an
appropriate metric by not by too much
so i want to show just quickly go
through the intuition for how this
result works and i'm going to focus on
this best response part
because once we know their best
responses of this form it turns out that
showing that there is an equilibrium
is used as reasonably standard tricks
from like the theory of fixed points
um but sort of the real meat of it is
showing that um
they're they're always our best
responses where you scale your
valuations by a constant factor
and so to show how these best responses
look like first we want to analyze
what these mechanisms look like from an
individual user's perspective
so from a user's perspective what are
they doing so they have various reports
they could make to the mechanism
and each possible report generates some
outcome and some payment
and so we can plot this on a graph right
where a point on this graph generates a
certain amount of value from the outcome
from the allocation they get
and a certain payment that they have to
they have to pay
we can plot out all the different points
that correspond to all the different
reports
and we notice that there's a frontier
right so
possibly by randomizing between reports
a user can sort of pick the best
possible way they could spend a certain
amount of money
and so certainly at equilibrium right
they would choose
if they're going to spend some amount of
money to select a point on the frontier
because otherwise there's something else
they could do that strictly better
right so really the mechanism what it's
doing is it's generating this frontier
of possible outcomes
which is payments per like that they
sorry
values that they could obtain for any
given payment
and because you can have this
randomization over outcomes this will
necessarily be a concave function
so now the optimization from a bidder's
perspective
is that they're going to look at this
value that they could get from the
mechanism which is this red curve
and they're trying to balance that off
against the convex disutility for
spending money
so the optimal way to bid will be the
way that maximizes this difference
right in this case in this picture it
would be the star
and so our claim is that this optimal
bid this report that generates the star
point will correspond to a bid that
takes the valuation function
and scales it by some alpha
well so how why is that true well i want
to point out that if these cur you know
because i have a concave function
minus a convex function um it's actually
going to be optimized at a point
where the slopes are equal of the two
curves
let's call that slope r
now my claim is about a report that
generates a point on the red curve
which is actually completely um
independent
of what's going on with this blue curve
so in particular let's imagine a
hypothetical scenario
where my where i have a hypothetical
bidder whose
value function is just r times p
their dis utility for payment is just r
times p
well note that then this star point is
actually still utility optimal
right again it's the point that where
the the um derivatives of the two curves
are equal
well what is the utility that this
hypothetical bidder gets
well it's the value of the outcome
minus the disutility for payments which
is r times p
well the utility function like the
strategic behavior of a utility function
is invariant under different scalings of
the utility function
so strategically this is completely
equivalent to an agent
who is um facing a value function that's
scaled
down by r and the payments are just
p quasi-linear right i just took my
utility curve and divided it by r
and the way the agent behaves is not
going to change if i just scale it's
just like what's the
it's just the changing the unit in which
utility is measured
but notice now that this utility that
i've described on the right here
is actually quasi-linear
but i started with the assumption that
this mechanism we're looking at
is truthful for quasi-linear bidders
which means that for this hypothetical
bitter it must
be optimal for them to report their true
valuation
in this scaled world which is just value
divided by r
well this is exactly what we were hoping
for right so now we're saying is that
it's always you can generate this point
on the red curve by declaring a report
which is just your value times this
alpha
which is 1 divided by r the slope of
this point
now that's the high level idea of the
argument i want to make some notes
first of all i've been thinking about
all this to this point in this case with
say additive evaluations
um we didn't make use of any properties
of evaluation function in this argument
at all really
um so in fact this result holds for
arbitrary evaluations on a very broad
class of social choice problems
sort of similar to vcg it does require
some technical conditions like
measurability and convexity of the
outcome space and so on um
see the paper for more details on that
i also want to point out that um this
proof is glossing over
a bunch of edge cases around tie
breaking right so i assume for example
that
there's a unique point where the
derivatives are equal
um which really has to do with you know
when i have a tie
at a certain bid if i handle ties
more carefully this interest you need to
handle things like discontinuities
um in the curves see the paper for more
details than that
this simple this simple sketch gets the
main ideas
great uh so now we know something about
the structure of the equilibria
let's talk about their allocations in
particular might wonder
whether the allocations that occurred
equilibrium are approximately efficient
in the economic sense of generating good
welfare now we need to be careful here
as i mentioned before about how we
define welfare because we're outside the
quasi-linear setting
and uh you know values are gener
measuring
notions of utility rather than dollars
it's not even clear how to trade off the
utility of one agent for another
so here we're going to do is we're going
to take a notion
of welfare that really you know
dives in on this idea that what we can
learn about an agent's utility
their value from different outcomes is
how much they're willing to pay
right this money is that is the unit by
which we're learning um and so we're
going to do is we're going to write down
the agent's
willingness to pay for an outcome this w
i of x
i to be the maximum amount that that
agent would be willing to pay to the
mechanism
to get xi as an outcome
as opposed to getting nothing getting a
null outcome okay so if we give them a
take or leave it offer
of x i or nothing um w y of x i is the
maximum amount that willing to pay in
order to get x i
um and notice we can just read this off
of the curve here
it's basically the amount that the agent
would be paying
so that their disutility from that
payment is equal to the value they get
from the outcome
okay um so we'll say that the
transferable welfare
is the sum of everyone's willingness to
pay for the outcomes they get the
allocations they get in our in our
outcome and we can think of this as
you know the agent's collective
willingness to pay
to sort of implement the mechanism's
outcome
now i want to notice that this
generalizes the notion of
standard welfare when bidders are quasi
linear right since the willingness to
pay for an outcome in that case is just
the value
it also generalizes the notion of liquid
welfare that's used when analyzing
budgeted agents
which is the minimum of the value and
the budget
but applies to these more general curves
as well
so now suppose the valuations are
additive and let's go back to our
example where we're using the vcg
mechanism which is just second price
auction per item
then what we can show is for
any valuation and cost of money curves
and any equilibrium
alpha which we remember is we know
exists
from our from our previous result
the allocation that is obtained has
transferable welfare
at least half of the transferable
welfare of any other allocation
right so this is a price of energy style
result the transferable welfare of the
result
of the outcome we generate is at least
half of the optimal transferable welfare
in the worst case over all equilibria
uh i'm not going to have time to go into
the details of that proof
um but the basic idea is um
share similarity to price of anarchy
style results for welfare
for simultaneous second price auctions
if you happen to be familiar with that
literature
but please see the paper for more
details
so to sum up we're analyzing here the
robustness of mechanisms that are
designed for quasi-linear agents
in particular when they're deployed in
environments where the agents might not
have linear value for money
we show that in those settings agents
scale their valuations
by uniform factors at equilibrium of
play
moreover we show that under an under a
reasonable notion of welfare which we
call transferable welfare
um we have a price vanity result uh
where we get at least half of the
optimum
at any equilibrium and as i mentioned
before we also have some results about
revenue
if we augment that second price auction
with reserve prices but see the paper
for more details about that
in terms of future directions our
welfare results
are specifically for additive valuations
it would be great to sort of generalize
this
and think more broadly about what
outcomes can occur
at equilibria in general or social
choice problems
also these are all resistance results in
particular
it'd be interesting to understand
whether equilibria can be computed
for example if we happen to know the
form of the cost of money curves that
the agents have
that's it thank you very much